es un nuevo capítulo en una novela con
protagonistas poderosos el hombre más
rico del planeta y una de las redes más
populares del mundo se ven nuevamente
enfrentados después de que el un mosco
anunciara que cancela la compra de
tweeter pactada en 44 mil millones de
dólares el anuncio se dio a conocer este
viernes por los abogados de moscú en una
carta arguyendo incumplimiento a lo
pactado señalan a twitter de no
facilitar información sobre las cuentas
falsas twitter no ha proporcionado esta
información o se ha negado a hacerlo a
veces twitter ha ignorado las
solicitudes del señor más que a veces
las ha rechazado por razones que parecen
injustificadas y en otras ocasiones ha
afirmado cumplir con ellas mientras le
daba al señor moscú información
incompleta o inutilizable las reacciones
no se hicieron esperar por parte de la
red social la junta de twitter se
compromete a cerrar la transacción en el
precio y los términos acordados con
moscú y planea iniciar acciones legales
para hacer cumplir el acuerdo de fusión
josé garcía experto en tics analizó para
france24 el impacto la retirada de moscú
del acuerdo de compra hay una cláusula
penal la va tener que pagar eso no se va
a poder salvar de ello pero twitter va a
querer mucho más dinero porque insisto
el costo financiero y el valor de la
acción se va a ver muy muy golpeados y
de no existe otra manera de poder
recuperar lo que sea definitivamente que
lo emboscó pongan más dinero el proceso
de adquisición inició el pasado abril
cuando twitter aceptó la oferta por
parte del magnate sudafricano quien
prometió eliminar lo que considera las
restricciones a la libertad de expresión
impuestas por la compañía de concretarse
la cancelación de compra uno de los
afectados podría ser el ex presidente de
donald trump quien espera retomar su
megáfono mediático